después de haber lidiado con muchos de
estos problemas de examen de ingreso me
di cuenta que hay problemas en los que
sólo esperan que sepas algo y de hecho
eso es lo que voy a cubrir en este vídeo
una de esas cosas que sólo esperan que
sepas lo que voy a hacer es desarrollar
la relación entre secciones cónicas y en
particular nos enfocaremos en la
hipérbola y una línea tangente hicimos
esto en un problema anterior pero no era
el caso general así que si tenemos
digamos que tenemos una hipérbola que
abre a la izquierda y a la derecha por
lo que tenemos la ecuación x cuadrada
sobre a cuadrada menos g cuadrada sobre
b cuadrada es igual a 1 si quiero
graficar esa hipérbola se vería algo así
ese es el eje x
este es el eje
abre hacia la derecha
abre hacia y abre a la izquierda y en
caso de que seas curioso este punto de
aquí si dices que es igual a 0 este
punto de aquí es
como 0
y este otro es negativa
negativa coma
lo que quiero hacer es encontrar una
relación entre estas as ibex y la
ecuación de una línea tangente así que
digamos que tengo una línea tangente que
se ve algo así
esto es tangente solo en este punto de
aquí y entonces se vería algo
algo así y digamos que la ecuación para
esta línea tangente es jay igual
m
x donde m es la pendiente más y en lugar
de decir b para la ordenada al origen
normalmente llamaríamos a la ordenada al
origen b para una línea pero ya usamos
la b aquí en la ecuación de la hipérbola
por lo que déjame llamar a esta
entonces la cee y esto es un poco
inusual esta va a ser la intersección en
sí
así que veamos si podemos encontrar una
relación entre las semis las es la paz y
las ves y estamos de hecho utilizando un
problema tipo examen de ingreso sospecho
que el próximo problema que haga también
va a utilizar lo mismo se han visto
muchos de mis vídeos de cónicas verán
que suelo demostrar las cosas desde los
primeros principios porque en la vida no
puedes sólo memorizar fórmulas no sabrás
de dónde vienen las memorizar has mal y
no entenderás lo que significan
realmente pero si vas a tomar un examen
de ingreso te recomendaría que y solo
porque sé el poco tiempo que dan a estos
problemas y si tienes que demostrar
desde los primeros principios no serás
capaz de aprobar los por lo que te
sugiero que utilicemos una relación
déjame dejar de hablar o más bien déjame
dejar de hablar sin dibujar así que solo
veamos dónde se intersectan y lo
importante aquí es que sólo van a inter
secar solo baninter secar en un punto
así que lo que haré aquí es resolver
para que cuadrada por aquí podemos
multiplicar a ambos lados de esta
ecuación multiplicamos ambos lados de la
ecuación por de cuadrada negativa por lo
que tenemos menos de cuadrada sobre a
cuadrada por x cuadrada más ye cuadrada
y ya multiplique por be cuadrada
negativa es igual a menos
es igual a menos b cuadrada
y ahora sumemos esto a ambos lados de la
ecuación y tenemos que cuadrada es igual
a b cuadrada
sobre
cuadrada por equis cuadrada menos de
cuadrada así que solo reescribir la
ecuación de la hipérbola y escribamos
esto también en términos de ye cuadrada
y luego las podemos igualar una con otra
por acá por acá en este color
amarillento si elevamos al cuadrado a
ambos lados tenemos que cuadrada
es igual
m cuadrada
x cuadrada más 2 veces el producto de
ambos términos así que es más 2 m
x + + se cuadrada
entonces para que se interese que en
ambos tienen que estar en el mismo lugar
en alguna xy y por lo que podemos
igualar está adecuada a esa ye cuadrada
y luego intentar resolver para x y aún
así no podré resolver para x porque hay
muchas variables pero podemos encontrar
una relación entre esta esta vez esta m
y ésta c para que sólo haya un punto de
intersección que por definición deberá
de estar en la línea tangente
hagamos eso tenemos m cuadrada m
cuadrada
x cuadrada + 2 m
x
cuadrada es igual a es igual a b
cuadrada sobre a cuadrada
x cuadrada menos b cuadrada y escribió
un ejercicio muy similar a este en el
vídeo pasado de exámenes de ingreso pero
aquí me quiero enfocar en el caso más
general para que tengamos algo que
podamos añadir a nuestra caja de
herramientas
así que escribamos esto en términos de
una ecuación cuadrática en x entonces si
restamos esto en ambos lados tenemos m
cuadrada m cuadrada menos de cuadrada
sobre a
cuadrada menos b cuadrada sobre a
cuadrada por x cuadrada por x cuadrada
aquí sólo le resta a este término
este término de acá y luego mi único
término de primer grado de x está justo
aquí por lo que es más 2
m
x2 msx y luego finalmente más
tenemos una cuadrada y luego de hecho
vamos a tener una más de cuadrada por
ahí así que esto va a ser esto va a ser
más se cuadrada
cuadrada más
d
cuadrada
ahora para que esta ecuación solo tenga
una solución déjame escribir esto va a
ser igual a esto va a ser igual
para que esto solo tenga una solución el
discriminante de esta ecuación
cuadrática y recuerda si yo cuando haga
la ecuación cuadrática y esto es
completamente indiferente por lo que
menos b
más o menos esto es la fórmula
cuadrática la raíz cuadrada de btr
cuadrada menos 4a
sobre 2
sólo vamos a tener una solución si esta
cosa de aquí si esta cosa de aquí si el
discriminante de ahí es igual a cero
entonces si ve cuadrada menos 4 hace es
igual a 0
sólo tendrás esta solución menos b entre
2 y por lo que en esta situación para la
línea tangente puede solo tener una
solución una equis que satisfaga esta
ecuación por lo que ve por lo que ve
cuadrada menos 4 hace tiene que ser
igual a 0 en la ecuación cuadrática
estas son best as y 6 diferentes de las
que estamos utilizando aquí por aquí por
aquí nuestra be es esa de ahí el único
coeficiente en el término de x y eso al
cuadrado es 4
m cuadrada
cuadrada y le vamos a restar a eso menos
es es todo esto de aquí y sólo para
simplificar las cosas déjame hacer esto
positivo y luego multiplicar esto por un
signo negativo y vamos a invertir el
signo entonces queda menos 4 pongo un
más aquí x y ahora multiplico esto por
menos 1 y ahora queda
cuadrada sobre a cuadrada - m cuadrada y
luego la c es este término de aquí este
de aquí s
cuadrada más
cuadrada
y esto va a ser igual a 0 si esta línea
es tangente si sólo tenemos si solo
tenemos una solución veamos la primera
cosa que podemos hacer para simplificar
esto es dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 4 y si hacemos eso esto
se convierte en y quiero hacer eso en
negro esto se convierte en 1 por lo que
podemos ignorar eso y este se vuelve un
1 por lo que eso simplifica nuestra
ecuación un buen tanto y ahora
desarrollaremos la multiplicación de
este segundo término así que tenemos b
cuadradas sobre cuadrada porsche
cuadrada eso es
cuadrada por c
cuadrada sobre a cuadrada
y luego es de cuadradas sobre a cuadrada
por b cuadrada entonces es más
a la cuarta sobre a cuadrada y luego
tienes m cuadrada negativa porsche
cuadrada entonces déjame hago esto en
otro color entonces tienes menos para la
m cuadrada menos m
cuadrada
cuadrada y luego tienes menos m cuadrada
por b cuadrada menos m cuadrada
cuadrada y por supuesto que todo esto va
a ser igual a cero
y tenemos este m cuadrada se cuadrada
aquí adelante m cuadrada
cuadrada aquí
y afortunadamente esto se cancela con
esto y ahora que nos queda cada término
es divisible entre b cuadrada
así que dividamos cada término entre b
cuadrada esto sólo se volverá un 1
esto será b al cuadrado y éste sólo será
1 y ahora multiplicamos todo por a
cuadrada para deshacernos de las
fracciones cuando multiplicamos todo por
a cuadrada este término de aquí se
vuelve se cuadrada
cuadrada este término de aquí es sólo b
cuadrada y luego
y luego todo lo que nos queda es y
tenemos esta - m cuadrada recuerda que
estamos explicada por a cuadrada
entonces es menos a cuadrada por m
cuadrada es igual a cero o podemos sumar
esto a ambos lados de la ecuación y
tenemos se cuadrada más b cuadrada
es igual a
es igual
es igual a cuadrada es igual a cuadrada
m cuadrada y lo que es importante de
esto es que ahora tenemos una relación
muy simple si sabemos la línea si
sabemos la línea si sabemos la ecuación
de la línea de aquí si sabemos lo que me
dice son tendremos una relación
interesante para a ive si sabemos los
valores de ahí b tendremos una relación
interesante para la ecuación de la línea
y tal vez si tuviéramos otras
restricciones podríamos resolver para
ellas pero pero vamos a tomar esto y
usarlo en el siguiente problema de
examen de ingreso que hagamos